i used to see those what's that do you  carry me i am  oh my god  i'm sorry  what are you sorry about mother is like  your biggest favorite that's awesome man  thank you i gotta call him hey what's up  man what's up pam i told him you got a  business i'll open the garage for you  and show you he's just load of [ __ ] my  brother oh the sneakers he runs his own  i love it good for him the ice creams  wow yep  it's good for them they keep blowing up  it's it's going well dude he watched you  all the time thank you man  thank you brother i'm so flattered by it  before you leave what were you actually  looking for basically i'm trying to get  people to understand you could go garage  selling with 20  buy [ __ ] flip it buy [ __ ] flip it  that's how i built my life